oh so we had a zillion in Wantagh did
you see the Steven Seagal karate
display video here's in it of course it
have we not talking about that for three
hours of a show because they did put a
four-hour pedo doc out on my house to
eat we were nuts deep into the Michael
Jackson documentary oh yeah man yeah
that Neverland leaving Neverland the
two-part documentary series on HBO that
came out on Sunday and Monday talked
about it all day yesterday it took me
forever to watch it yes a lot stopping
and making fun of stopping and wincing
stopping and coming yeah just interested
and nothing to get horny again to go
back to and then making some dinner and
then all of a sudden your wiener brushes
up against your bath well sure when you
remember like oh yeah still got
something that documentary I think I got
some I don't think we finished the wade
part I don't know if Wade got mushroom
captious yeah so Becky on walks in is
like were you watching the documentary
goes it's its paws where I came you're
gonna find out right where I popped he
goes he asked if I had the underwear Oh
dirty dog oh man that was a where do we
leave I'm hoping Shane watched it I told
you he did yes yeah coming in here just
step for step
oh yeah no he definitely saw it he's
pretty wigged out to everybody is yeah
it's a up documentary um
Christine had loved Michael Jackson if
she was younger
Becky how old are you so you love no JC
she said when she became aware of him
was almost through the allegations so
almost always came into it like Wireless
and this guy right cuz like he's a
piece of garbage
what a weird that's so crazy just
because of how colossal he was like how
big his fame was to that ye only knows
him as a molester first she goes you go
oh my god I love beat it by Michael
Jackson she goes is that the guy that
you need all those charges who gave that
molester a career wait that's the guy
that got called innocent on ten counts
in Santa Barbara
yeah I guess he makes music as he makes
songs too oh my god are they pedophile
songs is it all songs about to
the place then they play a pretty young
thing
if you saw it backwards it would look a
lot different I think it might even be
Jay Novak but early it'll be doing
comedy in New York he had a joke he did
it Caroline's one night you think it was
him but he goes uh he goes you know
Michael Jackson because if you really
read between the lines of the music the
information was all there for instance
there's a song called bad in which the
lyrics state I'm bad I'm bad I'm really
really bad you know Gino Gillis joins
the show oh look at all keynote are you
all skinny now he doesn't he's lost
weight dude hey did you drop a few now
you know what go over to next J cuz uh
did you drop a few lbs dude he's getting
thin hell yeah he's single white female
with me he's gonna start wearing
wrestling shirts no sugar no booze Wow
no booze tons of booze no sugars dude
what do you think I'm soft I'm
saying up I'm saying you lost it
you don't have the fire your head
instead of the funny I remember seeing
you sleeping on couches drink him eating
carbs I blacked out and on an air
mattress this week dude dude what a
gangster our resident hype man dude
which one you guys ate on an air
mattress this week this guy don't have
to go back to o7 I dare you to
sell when you moved your elbow and the
mattress moves in a different way when
you're eating oh sorry I was
watchin Caesars that's what I was afraid
of the whole time I was watching losers
on Netflix Greg's one eye great dark way
eat your side see with the other eye and
worried about busting through a mattress
oh my daughter I'm really unrelated
though - Christ
I'm late dude so great that she's just
blocked by the camera and Shane comes in
he goes and I'm getting hammered
yes munching box on air mattresses
that's my 16 year old daughter there's a
kid here no I put her out because she's
the only other person's room who's ever
eaten posing on air also that's James
parents behind me Jesus Christ both also
a guilty of eating clean air master this
is big are the car the phone lines
lighting up with questions for my mother
the answer's no you watched no you watch
all of me leaving Neverland I did you
watched both parts I did okay watch The
Oprah after-show did not did you go to a
robsons house and wait outside to talk
to him and get his opinion would have
dude Wade's pretty hot dude Danny moves
he glides for sure
he definitely really well you know
that if your tray if you're molested by
Michael Jackson you've got moved yeah
the safe Chuck in love drew the safe
yeah the safe Chuck kid comes off
clunk through the wait Rob since got the
rhythm yeah I mean that kid's gonna
throw back into it 7 to 14 you're not
around for seven years I think safe
Chuck's a little bitter cuz he got
bounced quick he didn't get the
franchise yeah I call you safe Chuck by
the way disclaimer none of this is cool
I'm just saying Oh grand scheme he's an
absolute monster Michael Jackson is I'm
just I'm getting into his head right now
I'm thinking how I would go oh you go
get robsons gonna take over then he got
the little Dominican kid who was just
but he sued quick he flipped for money
right was that the one that flipped for
money yeah and just when just when
Michael Jackson trusted him enough to
finally have sex with them this kid
flips on them yes I'm like Fredo that is
your movie the spot anyway like this
they're crying to each other do the Wade
Robson that I learned me and MJ have a
very similar sexual
Shayne rubs a lot when I meet a girl for
the first couple of months I make her
sit at the end of my bed the headboard
and then eventually I get the courage to
go in for a rim job there's a little
extra change trusty divorce when a horse
gives you a petting zoo do you think
when that safe Chuck kid and wave
Robison got together as adults they were
still a little hurt in their heart when
they were trying to one-upmanship where
he was like he came over and started
licking my butt on the bed he goes
sitting really do that for anybody else
and then that same Chuck he goes yeah
dude he told me that serious or they
find out that one thing is different
where we said I was the best answer he's
ever seen that that ages he told me I
was the best answer
he's probably lying you you're not even
a real dancer I'm trained prepared nice
Pierce yeah they should have a Westside
story of all the kids that he
dude that just like a dance-off who's
better at dancing
uh you got served yeah with all Michael
Jackson moves oh all the victims dance
off or the estate verses the victims in
a dance-off we all we all knew something
was happening none of us knew how
sinister it was but how didn't we when
we saw that he made them dressed just
like him and then walked holding their
hands everyone do that to my I would do
that to my girlfriends they were
wrestling she sure did I hope you make
your girlfriend's a feel actually Claire
was when I
Claire was wearing a sheets
sheets cam oh yeah you that's been a
really good game she like sheets thinks
aliens are gonna destroy the earth if
she doesn't wear stuff like you Claire's
cry oh man baby girls crying she's
crying to her sister she's like the
alien signal murder you suck bring this
I'll me them aliens
for scissors like the bucket Earth's
flat so who cares what's her what's her
what's her one sentence cool you know
you broke Corey what's our one second
what's your one sentence quote on what
her thing is yeah I've never seen it be
round
alright I'm already in this hole you'll
be fine you'll be fine dude this is a
safe space
this is flat she definitely doesn't know
how to operate satellite radio oh no
there's never get back to hear her he's
worried about getting but you know you
get in trouble with the whole thing
it's a girlfriend fight it's a whole
thing this is definitely realize that
with comedy sometimes it's Jay you've
got a good place you just let it fly but
sometimes you get in trouble no I don't
get Ivan got in trouble with this
current one but past ones have been like
did you yeah a wealthy girl was like did
you just on me on your show like oh
yeah yeah yeah you broke my heart what
do you think I was gonna do you hurt me
and I have a microphone in front of my
face
I will retaliate by any means I have to
make my love into a comedy bit well
we'll get back to Michael Jackson but
this just solidifies that you need to
come in when we do a pre record of
beyond the earth or curve beyond the
curve which is a documentary on Netflix
about flattering flattering yeah and go
watch that they are every situation you
know I like that my my stepfather's here
this is something very instilled in me
by him mm-hmm
when I was when I first got a tattoo
when I was younger and I have a bunch of
tattoos now I like tattoos however his
point from the get-go was smart you know
when I got tattoo he goes my name is
getting shape but whatever it is you're
trying to do with that tattoo yeah could
be solved if you were in shape and
everything I see what I watched when I
watched the documentary about the
alt-right and anti feh yeah polar
opposite sides the answer is all of that
and all it's just like you
just get laid or something man like if
you're if you're going to flatter of
conventions like so that's I don't know
man get plastic surgery before you do
that and try to make your face different
and we're gonna get what it's the
problem that's here is that you have
nothing to do so you're gonna want Flat
Earth clock saying I the thing I find
the funniest is that the
scientists are so right that they just
feel bad for the people they're like let
them have it
yeah they really are they're like god
bless if that's what you think you're
not gonna get into science you're not
gonna you know I mean well it's almost
my thing with the Flat Earth or two I go
you will you believe is big conspiracy
to cover up what I take the information
if they go you know we've been lied to
forever the earth is flat I go okay I
mean so my big dream of sailing from
Atlantic City to Los
Angeles via going around the world isn't
gonna happen well alright wait do
you understand yeah I was gonna go
around it still flat or not you can
still do that no you can't you can't
sail now you can of course you can't you
go around it I'm saying to go around no
matter what to fly to sail from Atlantic
City to LA you just have to go through
the Panama Canal talkin the scenic route
down flat or round that still works I
doing a poor job of D bump saying I'm
not I'm not the bunk of nothing just
don't work city in Atlantic City lost
I'm taking a flight I'm talking about
going this way to come around it it is
flat earth that would work you'd go off
the air guys you just made a flat
earther out of me if you're flat earther
calling my girlfriend's you had a
conversation with her I did not
it's secondhand is she all about it that
I'm abusing someone's trust right yeah
is that all is that is she all about it
we're talking about Michael Jackson
so it's a yeah it is pretty these kind
of he's combative don't really think
she'll get you hang on the flatter
Cermak pants
saying the Flat Earth Netflix doc made
me yell more than abducted in plain
sight and leaving Neverland
combined yes it's a rough watch well
that's why we're gonna do a whole
episode on it it is a rough watch but I
want one of those clocks the guy makes
will get one yeah dude you got a
birthday almost a year away yeah what
was so bad yeah it's it's pretty
ridiculous
leave it back - leaving Netherland there
what I wanted to bring up today was I
after watching this documentary you're
like who defends Michael Jackson besides
his family and that turns out who's
Wendy Willy do you want to speak up on
this blog Lou already already got rid MJ
he said he's done with it
black Lou got him out about our Kelly
reads our Kelly knows exactly the
that his name's Robert Kelly his name is
Robert Kelly Michael Jackson accusers
Williams really is a carved up freak can
you bring up the clip that you sent us
go Steve wait till you see ya now
Christine you said you think she's
playing devil's advocate in this clip it
looks like Wendy Williams dug up Michael
Jackson and took his face and put on her
face she faced off to Michael Jackson I
was gonna crazy eyes yes I want you to
take his face off so this is she's
terrifying she's just this guy on the
show with hers just explained to her
basically like a synopsis of the
documentary and this is her II actually
that strake I said something yeah well
first he was talked about how much
he gets it that definitely straight guy
oh the guy works or even talks the guy
wearing a hound tooth leggings suit
Jimmy said that Michael said that is the
greatest oh you think he was gonna side
go that side I swear I was about to say
the words I go how could they be
clapping for oh yeah guys dressed like
Sergeant Pepper just like
Dominican warlord
shuttle Michael hat and makeshift
wedding with the exchanged vows then
come down like little vows on paper and
send they're gonna be together forever
she's not listening to a thing he's
saying I know he's just waiting to talk
you can see in her face she's like okay
here we go and all I be thinking is this
guy's talking with sheer jealousy in his
voice brought them all the clothes
tell him to shop for whatever he wants
you took out the box of jewelry and at
that point I knew it was real
no one buys a rock like that for someone
they're not banging hey your balls deep
you're buying a red
shit-or-get-off-the-pot Mike you know
I'm saying do enough ding ding get the
wedding ring make this kid make this kid
an honest woman already oh yeah when she
went to her plastic surgeon and said can
you give me a permanent skeptical face
yeah
even if her face is always like it looks
like she jumped at the end of the show
by Wendy Williams audience and a
guy dressed like Michael Jackson
beat it yeah this is black people's flat
earth
I got our Kelly and MJ we got our Kelly
and Michael Jackson ever worked together
they didn't oh man he mention those
parties I'd say like the other vendor
I'd imagine those trailer talks in
between in between things child
trafficking is you have a sister yeah
you are not alone and he told one of the
girls that he molested that it was
allegedly that it was about her yeah he
wrote that for Michael Jackson I don't
know if they actually have something
were they sing together but that was a
hit there was yeah no for sure
great song back to wonder will he was
getting money yeah I got arrested today
we'll get sorry Kelly once I to file at
a time Jackson rest in peace this is my
this is my favorite part go back
two seconds because this is batshit
crazy
Joe Jackson is a piece of a legally
certifiable hunk of garbage and watch
what she says this is nuts this is
nothing I've been around long enough I
believe that Joe Jackson rest in peace
he did the best that he could in raising
this showbiz family Michael became the
star of the family anymore what the
he did the best he could he abused those
and he has done better I don't think so
my dad about it that's tops show my
dance my dad did okay and we didn't come
up with any hits I'd say how
hard did you get hit though I got
well where were you and your sisters
choreographing me my only sadness is
that Tito Jermaine Randy and Marlon will
never know the sweet beauty of being so
famous young boys are just giving you
their butts yeah he goes man I wish I
walked through a mall on my wish it was
my y'all I gotta take I to get a van I
had to make up some lies he goes I had
to create aliens and then give them
pills the fall asleep and say that we
were captive if you were getting a
captive sex slave child to Marlon
Jackson and you find out he's Marlon
Jackson at nighttime when you go to bed
and your weird cave he puts you in yeah
when a party's still go I mean I would
trade all this if I was just getting
molested by Michael Jackson
oh yeah it's better you want to up
yeah you get you get you you get
abducted in plain sight by the wrong
Jackson hey I got tea toad yeah oh man
oh man that sucks did you get to see
Neverland No
to go you know every live Torrance you
guys I had to drive out the Torrance and
it was pretty it was brutal man
guy had it an above-ground hot tub
didn't even have a wow there is no to
shop you can't swim in an above-ground
hot tub you just just can soak I'm
pretty sure it's only for athletes
yeah Tito uh real real little hand to
mouth out and talk
how was Neverland you go we eat all the
candy we could I mean sure there was
some sex but mostly fun yeah I had to
work at his real-estate firm I interned
Joe Jackson died he was always going
through a really windy tunnel he had
like that clown I beat all the
gay at of him he also has inner-city
latina eyebrows
he's a chola that's because my Colleen
is talented is be a little Joker the
Australian mom is the worst is the least
likable the Australian brother is the
most likable Jane yeah who's that his
name yeah yeah he was great the cop but
the cop we're doing outside I wanna say
we were sitting outside was that Wade
Robson
is the guy allegedly and I think
Stephanie Falcone says I think we
confirmed is he's the guy who banged
Britney Spears which broke up Britney
Spears and Justin Timberlake and then
Justin Timberlake made the Crimea River
song yeah and all we were doing that I
was making if he subtly made the Crimea
River lyrics just about making fun of
Wade Robson getting boof by Michael yeah
and all of it was like if Justin
Timberlake was like new and he's like
anyone my girl huh I just heard
that you got by the princess King
of Pop and then you came on his stomach
here's a song he's like first he kissed
your lips you twist his nips he
your butt & toned your hoe he got left
behind for my colleague called yeah and
you were home alone mmm-hmm
Danny held your hand say your parents
away hey candy cotton candy off your
dick yeah I have no problem leaving him
alone
Oh four days is nothing I love it let's
put wite-out sard when he was a baby boy
your son's gonna hang here with me and
I'm gonna have a take you far away
should I pull this book your parents
it's okay they're being tickled by
clowns for two hours you chose poorly
it's these other parents walk over a
carpet that just sends I'm gonna slide
down 15 levels what's up you got a cute
kid yeah me too yeah I can't help but
thinking we fed him right to them anyway
they drop down pretty good food at the
end of the night it could be worse in
the world about Michael Jackson being
the person who molest and rapes you in
your child is you absolutely if they go
real quick question no guys could it
have been worse yeah yeah this right
here is Frankie this is Frank Barney
he's an electrician he'll suck your dick
in his van and then punch you in the
head do you forget nothing the guy
literally is off the grid jail would be
an upgrade for him he can't wait to go
to jazzman's looking for shale three
hots and a cot we were watching it I was
watching and it was like this family got
to hang out at Neverland oh dude I might
take one one or two for my family to
hang you have a nice vacation if if
Trish sat me down and did one of those
speeches where she grabbed both really
waited two young shoulders and she went
Dan dad's gone
we can make up for it oh you're not
gonna have to have sex with your blood
live in a amusement park kiss a
guy kiss a guy you know when you go
outside you know when you go out back
and you see the back brick wall is broke
down from a drunk driver we would have
to see that anymore don't have to see
that you just gotta suck an adult-sized
penis you just have to make love to a
guy you really care about whole Kogan
brother I want you to come down to Tampa
you can all me up I'm like yes let's go
let's finish up his uh Wendy Williams
back in Michael Jackson not well she
doesn't need to hear this that's great
and you know she said is Michael
Jackson's mom's not well she doesn't
need to hear this
that's interesting because I'm Latoya
Jackson's thing that she said she was
forced into or whatever she claimed the
mom you know was well aware which I said
it makes the whole family like complicit
just garbage just bad people Gary
Indiana her taint a great place no I
thought her Goods now it's a shithole
I've driven through there a couple of
times yeah sheds I see it it's literally
a flat land of just sheds and then
inside those sheds are kids getting
dancing quick boss future kings of Pop
if you want it if you want to see a show
go to a Gary in the air talent show get
ready to blow it away let's go in that
barn is bumpin holy you wanna
you go to Gary Indiana they do a
talent show yeah that'll knock your dick
how good was it I don't know good enough
that I would let him rape kids you know
what admission is one kid that's the
toll it's not money how talented was it
almost forgivable that he kids in
that shed that's where they created all
that I said for sure yes but now I don't
know because I wouldn't Lords moving a
little bit slow but does this end his
legacy I mean is it district well it's a
he's definitely just not waiting there
might be a
mortal wound buddy when I was when I was
in the airport last night
in LAX in the whatever the JetBlue
terminal terminal five one of the bars
up there just has like you know it's
like a nirvana picture and one of them
I mean prominent in the front of the
place is Michael Jackson bad yeah it's I
don't remember all five yeah but for the
Delta yes they have a Michael Jack is a
bunch like a big old album album covers
and it's a big old Michael Jackson bad
and I'm like ma'am do you have to like
listen we played human nature on the
show yesterday coming back and I it's a
great song same thing they're still
funny what a dilemma to be in it really
doesn't discount their warrants is great
you know Weinstein's a monster but
Boondock Saints is a fun movie the knock
Saints does not hold up as a white as a
white trash Irish American that's
supposed to be like my go to
Good Will Hunting
that's our departed yeah yeah they speak
every language that's as we wrote it in
there and yeah it doesn't hold up but I
haven't seen aa Boondock Saints
sucks
you're gonna have a lot of your own
you're gonna have a lot of your own kind
did you like your be a lot of there's no
be a lot of four-leaf clover and the
Twitter handles real nice on the eve of
st. Patty's Day - dude I'm coming down
tomorrow no but you know I mean it's
closed it's March 17th it's pretty close
it's 11 days away March yes if it was
December whatever you know I was
on Christmas that was it was a
test
I need more Irish American white
celebrate st. Patty's Day like a black
girl celebrates her birthday it's it's
st. Patty's Day month it's st. Patty's
Month y'all
green beer all month hell yeah give me
an Incredible Hulk put a little bit of
green in my cobraman all dude yeah who's
gonna make fun of my culture yeah but I
don't believe any of this I do believe
that this is money for the families and
I do believe that Michael was having a
problem with drugs these fancy doctors
who will come to your house three
o'clock and you're on top of the
you have the freshest butthole splayed
out like it is sushi allegedly I'll let
you think and you are able to please
yourself I'm sorry I do not see this is
not his fault at all this is the doctors
fault
hairless void of wrinkles I mean I mean
just a flush surface with a hole in the
middle bounce a quarter off the actual
butt hole it looks like a pencil
sharpener in a wall grown from the earth
that's a natural flush like there's a
flush I walk to started dancing like you
I should just end up the next time the
next time Dan comes over I should put a
knuckle glove on my flesh light I go J
this is weird man what I don't care it's
like the fleshlight wants to be like me
yeah I'm just mentoring it hey this is
Dan Soder and big Jay oakerson from the
bonfire on Comedy Central radio sirius
XM 95 come back next Thursday for a new
episode of the bonfire should the
bonfire a lot set my name I did dude
because I love you